Oui, oui oui oui,
Vous avez bien lu le titre,
Les cacas sont de vrais trésors pour les archéologues.
Parce que ce sont des fouilles merdes (au sens littéral j'veux dire).
Parce que certains d'entres eux
Sont spécialisés dans les excréments
"Et pas parce qu'on fait un métier de merde, hein
On cherche des crottes, mais des crottes fossilisées:
Des crottes du passé."
Oui, 2ième information que vous pourrez replacer pour briller en société
(Ou pas)
Les cacas peuvent se fossiliser
"Et un caca fossilisé on appelle ça un coprolithe
De "Kopros"=excrément et "Lithos"=pierre."
"-Euuh... Merci Jean. -Sauf que...! Hehe, vous allez me dire:
"Mais comment c'est possible que ça se fossilise un caca?
Vu que ça se dégrade normalement"
Ah non mais on n'a absolument rien demandé."
En effet c'est compliqué d'avoir un beau Coprolithe
Et pour y arriver, le comportement du couleur de bronze est très important.
Par exemple s'il enfouit son "ferrero" ça aide,
Puisque ça évite l'oxydation ou sa consommation par des animaux mangeurs de caca.
"Bah quoi?"
Ensuite il faut qu'il y ait une minéralisation de la crotte
Et pour cela c'est mieux si l'artiste est carnivore.
Notamment parce que son alimentation contiendra plus de calcium
Ce qui facilite ce procédé.
On peut aussi retrouver des cacas très vieux, pas fossilisés,
Mais tout sec parce qu'ils ont été faits dans des déserts.
Et c'est génial parce qu'ils contiennent encore de l'ADN
"Ceux là, on les appelle pas des Coprolithes mais des Paleofeces,
Oui, moi aussi je trouve ça merveilleux la langue française."
"Jean-Mi, arrête."
Donc vous comprenez bien que c'est très rare
Et très précieux de trouver des cacas du passé.
C'est pour ça que c'est littéralement des trésors pour les archéologues.
"Bon, ok. Mais qu'est-ce que ça peut bien avoir d'intéressant un étron caillou?"
Eh bah plein de choses!
Déjà on peut savoir quel animal a démouler son brownie là,
Et donc quelles espèces (humaines ou pas) se trouvaient sur place.
On peut aussi savoir qu'est-ce que cette espèce mangeait,
Et donc qu'est-ce qui l'entourait en terme de faune et de flore.
Et bien sûr,
On peut déduire énormément d'informations personnelles
Sur le poseur de pêche lui-même.
"Hmm, alors lui, il était borgne et gémeaux ascendant bélier."
"Mais nan... T'arrives à savoir tout ça dans son caca?"
"Nan, j'déconne.
Par contre il avait des vers et la tuberculose. Ça ça se voit."
"Rah, tu fais chier."
"Ah bah! C'est l'cas d'le dire, ha.
Parce que le... Le rapport à la merde, haha..."
Et oui, avec le Coprolithe
On peut savoir si son designer était en bonne santé ou pas,
S'il avait des maladies, des carences, des parasites, des bactéries etc.
Ouais, y a des gens qui lisent l'avenir dans les lignes de la main,
Et d'autres le passé dans les lignes de la merde.
"Haaa... J'peux vous dire que vous êtes dans la merde, ehehe... He... Hum..."
Il y a 2 disciplines pour analyser les boudins fossilisés:
La "paléogénomique" qui étudie le génome des espèces disparues,
Et la "paléopathologie" qui étudie, par exemple,
Leurs malformations et leurs maladies infectieuses.
Bref.
Une véritable enquête et des métiers passionants!
J'ai envie de dire... Qu'ils doivent pas s'emmerder!
L O L
Y a, évidement, beaucoup plus de choses à dire sur l'archéologie du caca,
Alors pour en savoir plus, je vous suggère la lecture du super livre
"Retour vers le paléo" de Clothilde Chamussy, Jennifer et Pierre Kerner et Marion Sabourdy,
Et qui est ma source pour cette vidéo.
Et puis bien sûr pour tout savoir sur le cas, il y a le livre de Julien Meniel:
"Tout ce que vous devez savoir sur le plus tabou des sujets"
Et si vous avez trouvé que cet épisode c'était pas d'la merde,
Vous pouvez le dire en commentaire,
Mettre un pouce ou nous soutenir sur Tipeee,
Et surtout partagez à tous vos amis qui font cacas
(J'suis sûre que vous en connaissez plein).
Les dessins des petits étrons mignons ont été assurés par notre Leamlu préférée,
Allez voir son Insta, il est excrément bien!
Ouais elle est pas ouf celle-là...
Comme... Toutes les blagues... De cette vidéo... Voilà... Bisous...
🎵Enregistrement, Manon... Archéologie du caca...🎵
Sous-titres réalisés par la communauté d’Amara.org